hashtag textile is a celebration of the
remarkable and dynamic synergy between
contemporary fashion and technology if
you're interested in the future of
fashion and you want to think about what
may be coming down the road in terms of
how these production processes are going
to affect the making of fashion the
wearing of fashion what we've tried to
do is present that to the public so we
have a lot of technologies in there that
actually have not been employed on any
kind of mass scale but probably will be
in the future I think that what is
really fascinating about what you can do
with some of these technologies now is
this idea that it can be even more
personally expressive because you can
kind of customize it so you think about
digital printing for example there are a
number of websites already that you can
go on you can choose the images that you
want to wear on your body that's quite
amazing if you look at our cute circuit
dress that is embedded with micro LEDs
you could choose the imagery that's
going to appear on your garment and so
there is this incredible freedom of
expression this real amazing creativity
that I think you're going to be able to
achieve in the future we have quite a
few objects in the exhibition dresses
and shoes that have been made on a 3d
printer we have a dress from 2013 which
is this really beautiful cape and skirt
which is certainly wearable but it's a
slightly more conceptual piece but then
if you fast forward to two of the more
contemporary pieces we have that were
made just in the past year we have a
piece by three s4 which actually is made
out of kind of a crushable material that
you can actually
we also have a piece by nervous system
which is a Somerville based company
which is the 3d printed dress that you
can wear and you can also customise it
you can change the hemline you can
change the neckline you can change where
the petals fall as well as it's based on
a 3d scan of your body so it's going to
perfectly fit that was something
formerly reserved for a Couture client
so this idea that you can actually
access something that is custom fit to
your body is quite revolutionary yeah I
know I think that we are in an extremely
individualistic age of fashion I think
people now feel more comfortable using
fashion as a form of expression because
they have a platform a lot of that is
social media-driven
and I think that's really fascinating
and I think that a lot of what's
happening now with this customization
kind of plays into that as well I hope
that people leave feeling excited about
the future I hope that they leave having
learned something about what I think is
a very exciting synergy between the
fashion and technology worlds right now